28 miles off the tip of cornwall a
climate emergency is unfolding less than
a thousand years ago the isles of scilly
was a single land mass
now it's 140 islands and 2 000 residents
are battling the impact of rising sea
levels and intense storms this is the
main defense of our water supply which
is just the other side of this bank
protecting the island's water from sea
contamination it's just one of the plans
to ensure that future generations can
still live here what's the worst case
scenario for the people of the arts of
silly well evacuation basically because
we wouldn't be able to live here i'm not
talking about the next 10 years 20 or
even 100 years but it could eventually
lead to evacuation
the council says it must robustly defend
the islands and is spending millions on
protecting its coastline homes and
businesses
the majority of the population lives
here in hue town but it's also one of
the most vulnerable parts of the isles
at its narrowest it's around 130 metres
wide sandwiched between two beaches
climate change is literally squeezing
and eroding this community
twenty minutes by boat and we arrive at
saint agnes population eighty
farmers aiden and grace rear cattle but
also grow crops for oils and gin
so normally um we'd be harvesting these
plants and they'd be they'd be up like
this intense dry spells are making
business difficult
summers like this summer have made us
have to rethink completely we're going
to we're having to look at investing in
permanent irrigation systems now to see
us through it's just happening too often
for us to risk year on year the crops
failing
but climate change isn't just impacting
those on land
the wildlife trust says in 2017 nearly
all seal pups died after being swept out
to sea too soon by a series of ferocious
storms uh this is the main entrance to
the school
fifteen-year-old will schwartz is a
climate champion at the island's only
school he's passionate and fearful about
the future of the sillies it definitely
worries me the future generations won't
be able to have the same experiences
over here than than i did than my
generation did
which is a little bit sad and it's a bit
worrying because um
it we might already be too late
this island community is taking action
now
knowing climate change is posing an
urgent threat
to its very way of life
dan whitehead sky news on the isles of
silly